cree un grupo de cosas aquí y luego
copia y pegue otro grupo y tengo un par
más en la parte de abajo lo que quiero
hacer es representar el número de cosas
que tenemos en cada uno de estos grupos
con bases diferentes en sistemas de
números diferentes primero lo haremos
con base 10
a veces llamado sistema numérico decimal
decimal el prefijo de si se refiere a 10
sistema numérico decimal cuando alguien
habla sobre el sistema numérico decimal
no se refieren sólo a lo que
generalmente asociamos con los números
decimales que van a la derecha de la
coma decimal sino sobre la base de 10
en el sistema numérico decimal lo
podríamos pensar como si estuviéramos
pensando una manera de ver esto es como
si fuera dinero si tenemos un montón de
dinero intentamos representar un montón
de dinero con la menor cantidad posible
de billetes verán que intentarán buscar
el billete más grande que es más pequeño
que esa cantidad de dinero y de ahí
comenzaremos si quisiéramos tener la
menor cantidad de billetes aquí para la
base 10 queremos encontrar la potencia
de 10 más alta por la que se pueden
dividir todos estos objetos que tenemos
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
27 28 29 30 31 34 puede que se me haya
pasado alguno sobre el punto es que no
se puede dividir por cien pero sí se
puede por diez entonces podemos dividir
la potencia de diez más alta o el
debería decir la potencia de diez por la
que se puede dividir el diez dividimos
esto en la mayor cantidad de grupos de
diez que podamos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
separamos este de los demás
entonces eso es un 10 lo contaré para
revisar cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez buscar a otro grupo de 10 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 este de aquí es otro
grupo de 10
y luego tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
este de acá es otro grupo de 10
y esto de acá no es un grupo de 10 son
solo 1 2 3 4 5 entonces hay 35 objetos
aquí puedo representar estos tres grupos
de 10 lo escribiré con palabras primero
tenemos tres dieces tres diez o podría
ser consideremos tres grupos de diez y
con lo que queda no lo puedo dividir por
diez así que tengo que buscar una
potencia de diez menor y esa es uno
cuantos unos tenemos aquí tenemos un 12
13 14 15 16 es 3 10 más 51 y como lo
representaríamos en un sistema numérico
con base 10 tenemos el espacio de los 10
en el espacio de los 10 escribimos 3 y
en el espacio de los unos escribimos 5
y simplemente lo asociamos estos 35 pero
esto sólo está representado con el
sistema numérico decimal estamos
acostumbrados a él pero este es solo uno
de una cantidad infinita de sistemas
numéricos ahora hagamos exactamente lo
mismo con el mismo grupo pero esta vez
con base 2
hagámoslo con base 2 o donde sólo
podemos representarlo con dos dígitos
diferentes en base 10 tenemos 10 dígitos
diferentes para jugar este también se
puede llamar sistema numérico binario
sistema número numérico binario sólo
tenemos dos dígitos cual es la potencia
de 2 más alta por la que podemos dividir
esto recuerden queremos encontrar la
cantidad menor de monedas o billetes
queremos buscar la potencia de 2 más
alta por la que podamos dividir esto
cuál sería la potencia de 2 más alta
tenemos 35 cosas veamos la potencia 2 a
la 4 es 16 2 a las 5 es 35 esto se puede
dividir por 32 busquemos un grupo de 32
1 o mejor podríamos sacar 3 cosas
entonces esto es un grupo de 32
tenemos un 32
los libre así y no queda ningún 16 no
hay grupos de 16 aquí porque no podemos
dividir lo que queda por 16 no hay
grupos de 8 no hay grupos de 4
pero tenemos grupos de 1 recuerden que 1
es 2 elevado a 0 tenemos 12
o cuidado me salte uno dibujemos los
espacios aquí buscamos grupos de 32 lo
pudimos dividir por 32 luego intentamos
con 16 con 4 tampoco podemos dividir
esto
que queda aquí por 4
pero sí se puede por dos hagamos un
grupo de dos
un grupo de dos queda así tenemos un 2 y
lo que nos queda es sólo un grupo de 1
entonces tenemos usar otro color un
grupo d
ese color no es distinto
un grupo de uno no aún es el mismo me
cuesta cambiar el color un grupo de 1 1
cuantos como representaríamos esto en
base 2 para hacer esto debemos pensar en
los espacios este es el espacio de los 1
este es el espacio de los unos este es
el espacio de los 2
eso es para los dos este es el espacio
de los cuatros se me está acabando el
espacio estoy acaso el espacio de los
cuatros
este de acá es el espacio de los ochos
los haré un poco más pequeños para no
chocar con el diagrama ese es para los
ochos
ahora estoy acá es para los 16
estamos aumentando estamos multiplicando
por dos en cada espacio a medida que nos
movemos hacia la izquierda y este de
aquí es el espacio de los 32 lo estoy
escribiendo para no confundirlos
podría escribir los símbolos del sistema
de base en 10 pero eso los puede
confundir así que escribir las palabras
aquí para que podamos decir mira estos
son los espacios no quiere usar la base
en 10 para representar los espacios de
la base en 2
entonces ya formamos grupos antes
sabemos cuál es el grupo más grande
tenemos un 32 recibimos un 1 en el
espacio de los 32 no podemos hacer un
grupo de 16 con lo que nos quedó no hay
grupos de 16 no hay grupos de 8 no hay
grupos de cuatros hay un grupo de 2
tenemos un grupo de dos y hay un grupo
de unos un grupo de unos entonces este
número quedaría representado como 1000
11 este grupo de cosas 35 cosas en base
a 2
ahora quiero aumentar la dificultad el
sistema con base 2 tienen menos dígitos
que los que estamos acostumbrados a usar
en el sistema número numérico decimal
qué pasa si tenemos más dígitos
intentemos con base 16 eso es fascinante
base 16 o sistema numérico hexadecimal
no mejor no escribir el sistema numérico
aquí tendremos 16 dígitos tendremos
todos los dígitos tradicionales
escribiré todos tenemos
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
y estos son 10 pero ahora aumentaremos
la cantidad de dígitos que usaremos en
vez de volver a usar estos dígitos para
representar 10 representaremos el 10 con
una a
y representaremos 11 con un ave 12 con
un ace 13 con una d
14 con una 15 con una f
y ahora tenemos 16 dígitos tenemos del 1
al 15 más al 0 recuerden en base 10
tenemos del 1 al 9 más el 0 de alguna
manera tenemos símbolos para cualquier
base que queramos usar en este caso no
se confundan está a cuando hablamos de
hexadecimal representa 10 objetos esta
vez sería si digo oye tú me debes de
dólares te estoy diciendo que me debes
11 dólares
es solo otra forma de representar 11 en
vez de hacer un 1 y un 1 como lo
haríamos con base en 10 si tenemos estos
dígitos como representamos todas estas
cosas recuerden que ahora estamos en
base 16 escribamos el número de bases
siempre tendremos el espacio para los 1
si se saben las potencias es 16 elevado
a 0 se multiplican eso por 16 tienen el
espacio para los 16
tenemos el espacio para los 16 porque
estamos usando base en 16 o hexadecimal
si hacemos un espacio más tendremos el
espacio para los 256 describiré pero lo
pondré entre comillas del espacio para
los 256 puse 256 porque eso es 16 x 16 ó
16 elevado a 2 como representamos esto
primero tenemos 200 podríamos seguir
multiplicando por 16 pero podemos
dividir esto por 256 no podemos sabemos
que solo tenemos 35 cosas aquí por lo
que no usaremos el espacio de los 256
para representar este número si podemos
dividirlo por 16 cuantos grupos de 16
tenemos aquí contemos los lugares con
otro color
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
espero que no se me haya pasado ninguno
un grupo de 16 lo contaré de nuevo 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 un
grupo de 16 hagamos otro grupo veamos si
podemos hacer otro grupo de 16 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
todos estos de acá forman a otro grupo
de 16 definitivamente no podemos dividir
lo que queda por 16 tenemos 2 16 lo
único que nos queda es el espacio de los
unos
tenemos 31
en base 16 en exa decimal tenemos dos
cosas en el espacio de los 16
ponemos un 2
lo haré con el mismo color lo haré con
el mismo azul
tenemos 216 y tenemos 31
podrían decir oye esos 23 no estamos en
base 16 generalmente a veces les dirán
con qué base están trabajando pero
estamos con bases 16 esto no es 23
esto representa 35 cosas esto nos dice
que tenemos 2 16 y 31 y todo se suma 2
por 16 32 más 3 16 35
les daré más ejemplos de esto en los
próximos vídeos